kortnee what are some common mistakes
that are just simple not so much the
content of the screenplay but things
that people should be aware of when
submitting that they maybe don't submit
until you're ready you know it's like
don't submit if you're not ready and I a
lot of people want to be ready like
we've you know we've talked about being
impatient wanting to fight to end the
fight for a great movie to end and
they're like oh I'm gonna just submit it
and then they're bummed out that the
feedback comes back and they're like oh
they didn't respond you know and it's
like work hard on your script if you're
not ready to submit to blucat if you
don't think it's just your best work
don't submit it
don't submit it just wait three months
and submit to Nicholls submit to Austin
to submit to Sundance submit to
something now submit to the local state
regional contest that's six months from
now when your script is really good and
you're ready to do it and it's like
beautiful and you're really excited
about it but if you're not ready don't
submit that's the thing is as people
send in stuff where they're not intimate
with their material they don't know they
they don't even know you can tell that
they haven't gone back through it that
they haven't reread it that it's
overwritten it's too long and they're
and they're sort of like well I'm done
you look at it it's like and then they
get you know then they have a
responsible we're like yeah we're not
connected to it because it's confusing
or it's not clear or whatever and that's
the thing that I think most people again
you're in a rush to finish and so you
want it you want the you want the
adrenaline if I've just entered a
competition I'm making progress you know
it's sort of like and it's better to
just stay with the script and be patient
and make sure that you know your script
be intimate with your script I mean the
scripts that always come out on top with
blue cat now after all these years we
get more a lot more submissions there
are always scripts that are really tight
as a drum
I mean they're people that clearly do
they have worked really hard sometimes
people write a draft and they proofread
it and they send it in and it's like and
it does really well and they're like
that wasn't
second draft or whatever but generally
people you can tell people have like
worked really hard and they know
everything in their script like the back
of their hand and I think that's the
biggest thing that I would encourage
people to to make sure that you know
you're beat you should know your script
really well and if you know your script
very well then you know it either has
problems or a doesn't and if you know it
really well then you know if it does
have problems and you shouldn't be
submitting it to a competition
unless you're just like oh I just want
blue cats feedback or whatever and a lot
of people just do that and they're like
I just want to get some notes now you
know would you say when you were writing
love Liza were you obsessed with it and
that you were so in that world and
trying to you saw the one woman at the
game it meant a lot to you maybe because
you weren't working or whatever and so
you just focus everything do you want
that from who that same obsession and
sort of like this is everything right
here on this piece of paper well yeah I
mean I think that I just well I think
most people that are that have written
something special that does really well
they love it
it's I mean the thing about
screenwriting and going back to like
just my mission with blue cat and my my
the place in blue cat in my life in the
meaning is is that people you know
everybody we deal with is doing what
they want to do like it's their dream
it's their it's their passion it's it's
really important to them so I don't
think people are like well I'm doing
this screenwriting thing but I really
really like being a you know the
stockbroker that's what I really like
doing but I'm just working on
screenplays cuz I don't know you know
like I'm just doing it cuz I gotta do it
my mom wanted me to do it but I really
want to sell real estate you know it's
like it's not like that
so everybody we deal with is is like
it's important to them so everybody that
I talk to everybody that everybody's
like invested so there's not really an
issue of like obsession
you know investment priority with
anybody who's entering blue
God everybody's entering blue cat is
thrilled and excited they're not like oh
I won but I really really wanted to like
you know open that paint store and you
know I didn't that didn't come through
and that's what I really wanted and I
run the screen around in Ward and said
you know so yeah but that being said you
say people rush to get their screenplay
and you can just tell that they haven't
invested enough so then what is that
disconnect there you can tell that this
is what they want to be doing but then
they submit something sometimes not
everybody oh it's but but it's because
you know because we have to learn that
you know when you're when you're a
developing writer you know and you
ignore the feedback that you're trying
to give yourself but you're like no but
I want it to be done and it's done let's
go shoot it you know it's like then you
don't get the response you go oh I
should have kept rewriting I knew it
wasn't good I knew I had problems with
it but I submitted it to blue cat
anyways and then I got feedback and
clearly it's not ready yet
and then then this season the more the
seasoned writer the more you know
developer either one is more mature it's
like I'm not gonna submit that because
that's not ready I need to like make it
ready then I put my best foot forward
how do you monitor yourself in terms of
wanting to put something out there and
knowing okay you know what I know myself
this isn't ready yet yeah I mean I I
know like myself like yeah I mean I know
that it's not good enough and then it's
you know or I want you know sometimes I
like I want to get feedback so I have a
table reading or I have somebody read it
I mean like what do you think you know
you want some feedback but and you
definitely not gonna like send it off to
the producer or the actress that's
attached to your project or whatever
until like until you've done a lot more
you know and so there's certain certain
stages where I'm like you know it's like
you already know that this is broken you
don't need to like send this out again
or you nee you got a few already have
given yourself notes so we give
ourselves notes then we get notes from
other people then we can move it down
the
of the food chain but generally we have
to we you know it's it's all about being
honest and transparent with ourselves
and and having you know and knowing that
but you do learn that for by sort of the
early days when you're like well I'm
gonna just I want to see I wanted
somebody to read this and you just and
then you're like okay I think I'm gonna
wait next time before somebody reads it
cuz that wasn't too Pleasant they didn't
really respond and by the way PS I knew
it wasn't ready but I sent it to them
anyways because I just wanted somebody
to read it you just want to like make it
it makes it real when somebody else
reads I wrote a screenplay but after you
sort of get over the novelty of that
then you start to wanting like to make
write better work
you